Bailey: Okay, our next speaker
is Phil Dickerson who works
for The U.S. Environmental
Protection Agency,
and he's gonna
be talking about
how they have been
using Google Earth
to visualize real-time
air quality data.
Dickerson: Thanks, John.
As John said,
I'm Phil Dickerson
with The Environmental
Protection Agency,
office of Air Quality,
Planning, and Standards,
located
in Research Triangle Park,
North Carolina.
And I'm gonna be telling you
a little bit about
what we're doing
with virtual globes
and real-time
air quality data.
So first of all,
a little bit of background
about air quality.
Obviously air pollution
affects everyone.
Unlike some
of the other environments
that EPA is concerned with,
everybody has
to breathe the air.
Poor air quality
can aggravate lung disease--
including asthma--
heart disease--including
congestive heart failure.
And those kind of effects
result in
more premature deaths,
more admissions
to hospitals,
more trips
to the emergency room,
more visits
to doctors' offices,
more school and work absences
for folks that are affected
by those symptoms,
and more days with symptoms.
So basically,
very quickly what EPA does
in the realm
of air quality data.
The Clean Air Act
actually requires
monitoring and reporting
of air quality data.
A bevy of state
and local agencies
collect that data
and report it to EPA.
There's not an actual
regulatory requirement
for real-time reporting,
which will come into play
when I talk
about the AIRNow program.
EPA manages
the Air Quality System, AQS,
which is actually
the largest database
of air quality measurements
in the world.
It goes back to as early
as the 1950s.
That AQS data,
as I mentioned, is supplied
by the state, local, tribal,
and federal agencies.
And it's used
to determine compliance
with the National
Ambient Air Quality Standards.
So if you've ever
heard the phrase is,
"non-attainment area,"
that's what we're judging
based on this AQS data.
The reason I point that out
is because
the AIRNow program
actually provides real-time
air quality data
and forecasts
for the public.
So about ten years ago,
EPA found that
our region one office
in the northeast
was gathering up
real-time air quality data
three times each day
and creating maps
for the public.
So in 1997
we got some funding
to try to expand
that effort nationwide.
I bring this up in contrast
to the Air Quality System,
which we use for our
regulatory purposes.
This is actually reported
in real time,
which again is not required
by regulation.
And we have mostly a focus
upon the public.
This also leverages
existing monitoring activates.
The state and locals
are getting EPA grants
to do this monitoring.
And we're just building
upon that monitoring network
that already exists.
We have a very diverse
stakeholder community.
We have federal, state,
provincial, tribal,
and local air agencies.
And there are over
120 of those agencies
that are submitting
their data voluntarily
to the AIRNow program.
We also have scientific and
health research organizations
that are actually using
that real-time data
to study health effects
on humans.
We also have a lot of media
and public outreach groups.
Our data actually goes
to CNN, "USA Today,"
The Weather Channel,
media outlets like that.
We do a lot of education
and outreach
through the AIRNow program.
Ozone in particular
was difficult to visualize
since it's an odorless,
colorless gas,
and we actually
gave the public a tool
that they could kind of see
how ozone formed
in the atmosphere
and watch it move about.
We also have international
interests and activities.
We're actually piloting
a version of the AIRNow system
in Shanghai, China
right now.
The Chinese saw the success
the U.S. had with AIRNow,
and they wanted
to duplicate the system.
So we're actually designing
an entirely new system
that we'll use in Shanghai
and in the U.S. next year.
This bottom flow diagram
is a very brief description
of how the AIRNow system
actually works.
We have those 120 plus
state and local air agencies.
They submit their data
to the AIRNow
data management center,
which is actually
not far from here,
up in Petaluma, California.
They submit observations
every hour 24 by 7.
And they also
submit forecasts
to this
data management center.
We take that
and then turn around
and create
a national data set
and a national set
of maps and forecasts.
We then perform the function
of distributing that data
and forecast to the media
and also to the public
via our airnow.gov website.
And we hope
that that information
gets into the hands
of decision makers in the public
so that they can
avoid exposure
to unhealthy levels
of air quality.
On the right-hand side,
you'll see in 1997
this represents
that first regional effort.
EPA took that over
and the 2007 view shows
that we've expanded it
to all 50 states
and even the provinces
of Canada.
The bottom graphic shows
a special purpose map
that we drew
for the Alaska fires
a couple years ago.
Anytime there's
an emergency or a special event,
we'll contribute by creating
real-time data products
for that particular event.
Just a little bit more
about AIRNow.
As you've probably
figured out by now,
we do a lot of coordination
between the state and local
agencies and the media.
We provide centralization
for all this air quality data
that's collected at various
levels across the country.
We convert
all the raw data
to the Air Quality Index,
which is our public tool
for recording air quality.
It's a five-color system
that also contains
health effects information
so that the public
can actually figure out
what the air quality is
and what they can do about it.
And we do a lot of education
and lots of distribution.
Over on the right-hand side
you see some of the many ways
we distribute
this air quality data.
That first one there
is actually what I'm gonna
show in a minute,
which is one of our
KML products.
And then we have
contour maps of ozone,
which you see right beside
the Google Earth window there.
We also get our data
onto CNN.
We have a system
that allows you to subscribe
to get real-time
air quality alerts
on your cell phone
or pager.
And we also get coverage
on The Weather Channel,
"USA Today" and various other
media outlets.
A little bit more
about some of the products
we do in the AIRNow system.
As I mentioned,
we have real-time hourly data.
We have forecasts coming in
for over 300 cities.
We produce a national outlook,
which is kind of like
the weather map you
see on TV at night
that predicts
where air quality problems
will occur
in the next day or two.
We do news stories
for, um, particular
wide regional events
or in special cases
like wildfires.
We have webcams
so that people can visually
get an idea of what
the air quality looks like.
And we do yearly
air comparisons
to show how this year
compares to last year
or the last five years.
So what we're doing
with KML--
We actually have
a dynamically-created KML file
or several files
that we create.
We've got the most current
Air Quality Index,
and we update that every hour
as the new data comes in.
We have today's and tomorrow's
forecast Air Quality Index.
And those are all updated
on an hourly basis
based on the latest data
that comes in.
The KMLs also
give more information
via pop-up boxes.
They give you the ozone
and particulate matter
AQI concentrations
for a location
and give you links
to more information
in case you have
other questions.
Outside of my program,
EPA is also doing some other
air quality applications.
We have a KML file
for emissions data.
It has a really neat feature
where basically
the height of the balloon
shows the total emissions
for a facility,
and I'll show that
in just a moment.
We also allow people to see
where the actual air quality
monitors are located
via a KML.
And that's
a very neat function
because in the past
people might find
the address of a monitor,
they might be able
to plot it on a map,
but with Google Earth
you can now actually see
what's around that monitor
and detect
if there are schools
or parking lots
or if its near
a busy intersection,
things like that.
So we've come to the part
where I'm gonna try
to do some
live demonstrations,
which is kind of
the technology equivalent
of a bungee jump,
but we'll hope it works.
First the location
of air quality monitors.
This takes you to
an EPA web page.
And we monitor for a variety
of different pollutants,
so you can pull up
these different layers
depending on the pollutant
you're interested in.
I'm gonna click
on the ozone layer.
Oh, that was
an interesting choice,
the ozone layer.
This is actually
ground-based ozone,
so don't get that confused.
So what we're doing here
is we're pulling up
a live KML file
of the actual
ozone monitoring locations.
And you can zoom in on this.
Having a little trouble
with my mouse.
Here we go.
You zoom in here.
Whoops.
Okay.
You can actually see
the monitoring locations.
And if you click on one,
you can get more information
about that particular monitor.
So you'll see here this
particular monitor I chose
is in Salt Lake--
near Salt Lake City in Utah.
You can get a lot
of different information
about the monitor itself
that comes out
of our air quality system.
And you can even download
some of the historical data
for that particular site.
Um, obviously,
you can zoom in closer
and see what kind of terrain
the monitor has around it
and get a lot of different
visual information.
So I'm gonna jump back out.
Whoops.
Didn't mean to do that.
Okay.
This next one is actually
a KML file
that references
three other KML files
which give you information
on current air quality
and forecast.
So again we're loading
Google Earth here.
We're grabbing three files
that are generated every hour
by the AIRNow system.
One has the latest conditions
at every major
metropolitan area.
The other has
a forecast for today
and a forecast
for tomorrow.
And I'm just gonna
zoom in on one here.
You'll see there's one
in the Denver area.
When you mouse over it,
you see
the current AQI is 94,
which is a yellow AQI.
If you click on it,
you get a pop-up box.
And you'll see here
immediately the PM, 2.5,
AQI is 94,
the ozone AQI is 32.
EPA regulations require
that the cities report
whichever is highest.
So that's where
the 94 is coming from.
Okay, and then over
on the side
you'll see
the radio buttons.
You can switch
to today's forecast.
There's another view,
and it will take it
a minute to load.
You can see the forecast
for Denver for today
is that it will reach a 50.
And if you click
on that again,
you'll see that
the, um, 50--
It looks like ozone and PM
are gonna be 50.
Interesting.
So that's
the forecast for today.
Similarly, if you click
on the next radio button,
you can get
tomorrow's forecast.
And you'll see it's 50
for tomorrow as well.
One thing
I forgot to point out.
Just so you know
there's no tricks up my sleeve.
If you'll notice here,
this data was at
3:00 Mountain Standard Time.
So it is almost
real time there.
And lastly,
another group in my office
does national emissions
inventory,
which is a collection of all
the facility emissions data.
They've also done a KML file
with that data.
And on this one,
when you bring this up
it'll show you the locations
of actual plants
across the country.
That's why there's so many
of those little balloons.
And if you zoom into one...
you'll see the balloon
gives you more information
on that facility.
It also gives you a graph
of the different emissions
coming out
of that facility
and their relative
contribution to the total.
And my favorite feature
of this particular map
is if you rotate
the map like so
the height of the balloon
actually is the total emissions
of those sources.
So when you look
across the landscape,
you can see the highest balloons
are the facilities
that are emitting
the highest amount
for that particular area.
So if you click
on one of those,
you'll see its emissions
are fairly high
compared to some
of its neighbors.
Okay.
And that is about all I have.
I'll encourage you
to "invisit" our--
to visit our website,
airnow.gov,
where you can find
a lot more information
on air quality,
including information
about the Air Quality Index.
You can get data, forecasts,
news items, publications,
and a lot more.
And at this point
I'll take questions.
Yes?
Ah.
Yes, the question was,
"How do we do forecasts
and how good are they?"
The forecasts
are actually done, again,
by the state
and local agencies.
And they use a variety
of different methods.
Some of them are statistical.
Some of them
are numeric models.
And every now and then,
they actually use
some human intuition,
which you could also
call a guess.
And, um,
so the different methods
have different degrees
of accuracy.
And it also depends a lot
on the weather.
'Cause air quality
is very much affected
by the meteorology.
So as far as accuracy,
kind of a rule of thumb
is it's somewhere in the range
of 70% to 75% on average.
But it varies a lot
depending on the area
and the technique.
Another thing I should add
is our friends at NOAH
have a national
air quality forecast model
for ozone right now.
So if you go
to NOAH's website,
you can actually see
their numerical model
of the entire country
for ozone.
And they're doing
an experimental domain
for particulate matter.
There's a lot of different
products out there
that figure into
the forecast.
Okay, any other questions?
Thank you.
[applause]